hey david ben shapiro was called out
right in an article recently written
about him then the article was corrected
and it then just called him a
conservative is ben shapiro actually
alright yeah so an article was written
about a right winger ben shapiro
I believe it was in The Economist and it
named him an alt right sage I think was
the word that it used then after people
said he's condemned the alt writer he's
criticized the alt right he's not
alt-right himself
I believe the headline or the sub
headline on the article was changed to
radical conservative or something like
that so the question is is here isn't he
all right
he's criticized the alt-right some of
the on the alt-right don't like him so
let's take it in a few different ways is
ben shapiro by identity alright i think
the answer is no he's not identified as
alt right the alt right isn't
particularly filled with jews ben
shapiro is jewish although that doesn't
mean one thing or the other definitively
but we're starting to kind of paint a
picture and ben shapiro also has been
critical of the alt-right as a movement
if not further ideology
maybe more further tactics and the the
way that they have tried to implement
their points of view now when I say that
I'm not saying Ben Shapiro's ideas are
objectively better worse more or less
damaging than the alt-right on the basis
of being yes or no part of the alright
Ben Shapiro and the alt-right can both
be distinct groups and have equally bad
ideas or equally irrelevant ideas or
whatever now on the issues we would be
sort of stupid if we ignored the reality
that there's lots of ideas that ben
shapiro does share with the alt-right
there are points of overlap people are
poor because they're lazy or they want
to be or they just haven't decided yet
that they're not going to be poor
anymore okay i mean i'm not these are
not direct quotes but these are ideas
that generally are common to ben shapiro
and to the outright lower taxes on rich
people okay i mean there's many more
groups than just been shapiro and the
alt-right that have that ideology but
they share it make a bore
more difficult to get enclaves of the
alt-right believe that although part of
the alt-right is sort of indifferent to
the issue of abortion so my main
criticism of calling ben shapiro
alt-right isn't that there is not a lot
of overlap in the ideas it's that
Shapiro to me has always been an
establishment right winger an
establishment sort of reactionary alt
suggests that it is not establishment
it's an alternative to the establishment
right overall ben shapiro both by
political ideology and by his place
within sort of the media milieu is an
establishment guy part of alt is that
there's this outside insurgency sort of
element to it
Shapiro's just an establishment
reactionary conservative who yes has
sort of aligned himself with this
intellectual dark web which has kind of
that they want to claim to be this this
outsider insurgent thing whether they
are or not can kind of be debated and
the you know the other reason I think
that Shapiro is much more in line with
the traditional right-wing reactionaries
than the alt-right
is that he's way more religiously
oriented than the alt-right as a
movement certainly many alt rightists
are often religious individually but not
in the way that Ben Shapiro is in terms
of how his religion directly I mean you
know that famous thing where Dave Rubin
asked him if he'd baked him a gay
wedding cake or something like that and
he said no I wouldn't because I'm an
Orthodox Jew but I would still be your
friend the direct influence of religion
on Ben Shapiro's politics seems to be
different than not than the alt-right
but in the end this is an overblown
focus on labels reactionary
right-wingers conservatives and the
alt-right have many areas of overlap
they disagree in some ways and they
probably disagree about implementation
they may disagree to some degree about
Donald Trump but I don't know that I
would go crazy focusing on the labels
economist was probably wrong to say ben
shapiro is an alt right sage and i don't
think it was necessary to say that to
have an article that is otherwise
accurately assessing his political
beliefs we've got a great bonus show for
you today
become
member or a patron to get instant access
to the bonus show I am hosting the David
Pakman show on Monday Tuesday's a travel
day out to Las Vegas Nevada where a
number of progressive media hosts will
be meeting for a biannual way is
biannual every other semi annuals every
other biannual is twice a year for a
biannual meeting of the minds and I'll
be broadcasting from Las Vegas Wednesday
Thursday Friday next week but I will be
in studio on Monday